moi ce qui m'a toujours intrigué dans
mon métier c'est toujours d'essayer
d'aller voir ce qu'il ya derrière le mur
là où on voit pas et donc qu'est ce qui
se passe dans la tête d'une institution
quand elle dort parce que c'est ça cette
métaphore elle dort et pourtant il s'y
passe des choses c'est la première fois
qu'une équipe de tournage pouvaient
accéder à des lieux qui n'avait jamais
été filmée parce que l'objectif c'était
de ne pas montrer les vedettes mais de
montrer nombre la nuit c'est toujours un
peu particulier
alors que paris d'or un petit peu ici
c'est la ruche travail
c'est un ras-le-bol
quoi
et on peut quelquefois pété les plombs
aussi donc bien pas paresseux mais nous
rajeunit parfois ya cette femme un peu
effacé au moment où je l'interviewais
doit être minuit tout seul à la buvette
avec deux hommes qui sont bien
sympathiques mais je suis pas sûr
qu'elles le soient super contente d'être
là donc oui oui la politique parfois
fait des ravages parfois la politique
laisse brise des groupes
c'est aussi un engagement lourd lourd et
qui évidemment que les français ne
voient pas c'est par ce tunnel piétons
au troisième sous-sol que les députés
peuvent rejoindre leurs chambres leurs
bureaux aussi
bonsoir bienvenue donc aux experts verre
de bienvenue dans le gîte
quand vous êtes un député de la majorité
pour éviter de vous faire marcher trop
longtemps on vous met dans l'hôtel et le
palais quand vous êtes un député de la
troisième zone de l'opposition vous vous
avez le droit on sent un ce qui était le
cas de jean claude sandrier quand on a
tourné ce document député communiste de
bourges c'est moi qui fait le lit du
vent conduisent
pyjamas ces personnes qui me lemaire
c'est moi dans ces lieux quand le
silence et là il ya quelque chose il ya
une énergie et il ya un huissier de nuit
qui m'emmène dans les combles du toit de
l'assemblée au move des trappes on passe
on monte un escalier
je sens que en patinant il en a encore
comme on dit sous le pied il prend une
clé et il déverrouille un cadenas pousse
une porte et nous voilà cette fois ci
sur le toit dernière serrure à ouvrir
avant de rejoindre le fronton du palais
bourbon à plus de 27 mètres au dessus du
sol
vue imprenable sur la tour eiffel et la
place de la concorde
[Musique]
je me retrouve à califourchon sur la
pointe avec le drapeau qui flotte sur ma
gauche
or ces pseudos muscu l'un comme joie
mais c'est une joie tellement intense
d'être là où personne n'a pu aller
auparavant
[Musique]